I want to welcome everyone it looks like
we have a really good turnout of NLM
trainees which is good and we're going
to hear today from Travis Campbell who's
going to present the findings of his
doctoral symposium Travis is a as all of
you know is a PhD student and NLM
trainee who hails originally from Little
Rock Arkansas and went to did his
undergraduate studies at University of
Arkansas so take it away Travis okay
well thank you for attending today this
is my symposium where I'm talking about
the general area of research that I'm
hoping to pursue so I appreciate any
feedback after I'm done and if not today
by email the title is knowledge
representation and post-traumatic stress
disorder applications and I want to
discuss some of the current efforts and
possible future research opportunities
for me so I'm going to give a quick
background of PTSD and knowledge
representations then I'm also going to
discuss three projects so please forgive
me for referring to my notes but I'm
going to try to cover a lot of
information and i'll also i'll bring
this back up the outline to kind of help
us stay on track and to hopefully avoid
some confusion so post-traumatic
distress rack stress disorder as defined
by the dsm or the diagnostic Statistical
Manual for mental health is a condition
resulting from exposure to direct or
indirect threat of death serious injury
or physical threat some of the common
symptoms of PTSD is for current thoughts
of the traumatic event irritability
anxiety hyperarousal difficult
difficulty concentrating and left
untreated the symptoms worsen and lead
to further serious problems such as
clinical depression suicide
and violence and and spousal abuse and
there are many levels of post-traumatic
distress there's acute post-traumatic
stress there's chronic pts with delayed
onset and another more general category
that a lot of combat troops acquire is a
it's called combat operation stress
reaction and so a large focus of my work
will be on the combat-related
posttraumatic stress because that's the
clinical notes that I've been working
with and that's the notes that I will
have in the future but not to get too
far ahead of myself but the knowledge
base that I will be designing is easily
transferable to other types of
post-traumatic stress and other
subpopulations and so some of the
statistics with a post-traumatic stress
up to twenty percent of adults in the
u.s. that experience some type of
traumatic event will will have
post-traumatic stress women are about
twice as likely as men and there's
higher rates that have been found in
african-americans Hispanics and Native
Americans compared to Caucasians
children that survive specific disasters
have pts and about a prevalence of
thirty to sixty percent
in combat troops they studies very on
the numbers but some say that one in one
in five soldiers that returned from Iraq
or Afghanistan will have post-traumatic
some form of post-traumatic stress and
recently an incidence rate had reached
fifty percent and one time period and
also it's of note of last year for 2012
the suicide rates were at all-time high
at 22 times per day but even with this
high rate it most experts still thinks
it's under detected and a lot of the
under detection has to do with these
symptoms that show up much later after
the trauma has occurred and so finding
veterans with post-traumatic distress as
one problem but trying to get convinced
them to seek treatment as another
according to a 2008 ran study as many as
seven in ten veterans that are offered
mental health care refuse it and surveys
and focus groups repeatedly show that
the attitudes and beliefs of service
members and veterans still have a
negative stigma with seeking care and
another reason of under detection that's
veterans have expressed as frustration
with a v8 likely because of difficulty
in finding an appropriate treatment many
of many veterans expressed that the VA
has a difficulty understanding their
problems and unfortunately they do not
come forward and often seek
self-medication but a reality is is that
the VA has made some demonstratable
improvements in the overall care of
veterans but it also has major hurdles
especially with regard to PTSD diagnosis
and treatment and also the growing
backlog of disability claims
improve a--let's is higher because
recent veterans have a number of unusual
circumstances such as more frequent and
longer deployments also much of the
stressors that take place are in combat
urban environment so they have trouble
separating the war zone when they went
over to the urban environment when they
come back home and also our treatments
and diagnosis and you know advances in
surgery and medical practices have
improved and so also in front-line
technology so a lot of these soldiers
that would have been lost in past Wars
we're saving them now but a consequence
was that is that a number of returning
troops have a higher percentage of
psychological disorders and because of
this high prevalence the healthcare
system both VA and all over us is not
really prepared to handle this this high
number the problem in many of but
there's a lot of there's a lot of good
programs and projects that are underway
and and striving to combat this disorder
but the problem with many of the
initiatives that are taking place is
that they're operating in silos instead
of collaborating but even if they were
actively seeking to collaborate there's
a lot of interoperability issues to
overcome between the different
facilities and so these initiatives
share many of the same goals and they
all have needs too much of the same kind
of information and so from an
informatics standpoint one way to
support the health care system is
through initiatives of health
information system development in the
form of information extraction or
natural language processing tools and
projects and developing these we can
give assistance to all healthcare
systems
and so one of the areas that we are good
at is managing information with our
research literature but as we all know
the research literature it's already
vast and its continuing to grow and so
we must continue to find ways to to
improve the management of this
information and another area that we're
all so good at is with accumulating
clinical notes in our EHR but a large
percentages is in the narrative free
text and especially this is especially
true for mental health information
making automated automation of its usage
particularly challenging and so we must
continue to develop and improve our
information systems to support both of
these types of information on PTSD and
this could come in the form of
automating automating automating
clinical processes or developing tools
to help clinicians and researchers to
better understand the disorder but
before we build these tools we must
consider standards and interoperability
and ways to maximize collaboration we
must consider the various weight terms
and definitions are used in the
healthcare research community and so
what we must think about is knowledge
representation and a knowledge base that
maximizes the capture of meaningful
information there's various types of
knowledge representation but for the
majority of today I'll be discussing
ontologies this appears to be one
structure that is robust enough to
handle like the organization that the
post-traumatic stress needs
and so often when we think of term astre
extraction we think of well why can't we
just do a text search and retrieve that
term or even a regular expression and to
to grab that term well sometimes you can
but with an on with the use of an
ontology you cannot not only capture
these terms you can also overcome werdum
ambiguity contextual issues we can
capture temporal informations but such
as the specificity or the intensity of
terms and we can also capture synonyms
when words are negated and since we are
talking about human type texts we also
want to capture misspellings and so
terms describing what we what we're
looking for it can also help us find
information a common example in the
mental health domain is the term
hallucinations well we can easily search
and find the word Lusa nations and
clinical notes however sometimes the
provider will type exactly what the
patient says and they may not say
hallucinations they may say that they're
seeing things that aren't really there
well we would like to and knowledge
structure smart enough to pick up those
instances when the words that we're
wanting to acquire not necessarily
explicitly clear so some of the
characteristics of a good knowledge
representation system coverage means
that the knowledge representation covers
a depth of information and without a
wide coverage we can't really resolve
ambiguity also understood by humans good
KR will be viewed as natural language so
the logic of it should flow freely we
need to be able to understand what the
system knows and be able to draw
conclusions from it also by being
consistent we can eliminate redundant
knowledge or conflicting knowledge and
our knowledge base should also be a
it also should be be consistent and
eliminate redundant or conflicting
knowledge and be a medium for efficient
computation and also the knowledge
representation is used as a model to
object to model our objects in the world
so we should be able to easily modify it
and keep it updated lastly should
support intelligent reasoning so in
order to maximize our efforts
intelligent reading reasoning for the
system should represent the knowledge
base in a way that we can maximize its
usage and so ontology is kind of fit
this criteria as a strong robust
structure so for the remaining lecture
many of the projects that i will talk
about use in all those representation
and use on till ontology zor ontological
artifacts so ontology the word ontology
has been used in a lot of different
formats it's originally originally din
philosophy and it's been used in
information technology it's also been
used in artificial intelligence and now
it's commonly used in bow bow
informatics and the most widely
definition for for the bow informatica
mutti is a specification of entities or
concepts relations and instances and
axioms in a specific area of domain and
so with this model
trying to display that an ontology can
conceptually be thought of as a model
that represents knowledge but it also
captures relationships in an ontology is
a form of knowledge management that
facilitates communication between people
and organizations data it also can
improve interoperability between systems
it captures knowledge is a model that
can be then be queried by users to
answer complex questions so it's more
and more medical and biomedical
knowledge accumulates in computers the
problem is efficient retrieval and
analysis of this information it can be
difficult for researchers to stay
current on the latest biomedical
knowledge and because the problem is
that the data is found in a lot of
different formats a lot of the
information overlaps with one another
they use different terms to the
different different definitions to
define the same terms and so all of this
different formats a way that information
is collected is difficult to understand
the relationships between the data so
this makes selecting well essentially a
lot of the researchers need much of the
same information but they need it in
different meanings so this makes
building a knowledge base that handles
semantics well very important
so some of the purposes of an ontology
it can be used as a reference for
referencing information and thought of
as a schema that describes a current
domain and there are many types of
structures that are ontology like such
as controlled vocabulary which is a
collection of vocabulary in terms to
reduce ambiguity people also think of
taxonomy which is a controlled
vocabulary terms that arranged
hierarchical and then thesaurus same
thing the vocabulary terms but it's a
ranged as a as a specialized network but
an ontology can also be thought of as a
software artifact that is typically
created to meet a specific use case so
in literature the term ontology is is
often used interchangeably with these
ontology like structures so sometimes
the its actual capabilities get
minimized but some of the benefits of
using ontology is a common vocabulary
for shared understanding and it enables
reuse in a domain and some of you might
have heard of a semantic web on
technologies ontologies are the backbone
for this type of technology that enables
better use and reuse of information and
they also support reasoning in
applications and the biggest difference
between an ontology and these ontology
like structures is that like these other
structures that can be read by humans
but an ontology is also a
machine-readable format so we can use it
to manipulate it for decision type
purposes often in combination with with
business rules
and so
this by being machine readable it could
support researchers and automated
reasoner's what's called classifiers and
this is to infer knowledge that's not
necessarily explained not necessarily
explained in the ontology and it can
also capture non hierarchical
relationships which is sometimes
important for highly technical projects
or complicated software and then lastly
by providing knowledge as models and
templates we can assist in the
automation extraction of information
okay so the first project I'm going to
talk about is the common data elements
project and this is the first of the
projects that related to the knowledge
representation that uses ontological
artifacts and so this project was
started out because of the different the
vast variety of how data is stored and
they wanted to overcome the barriers of
data sharing and doing and to do this
they want to identify common data
elements that all researchers are using
and develop common definitions for those
terms so essentially so all researchers
can know that they're talking about the
same thing and so this project is meant
to help investigators conduct clinical
research through the development of
uniform formats by which which data
elements can be systematically collected
and shared across research communities
common data element is essentially a
logical unit of data returning to one
type of information and it's derived
from broader definitions that are used
across the research community it also
has a name and a precise definition and
if applicable it has a code so this is
basically a use to standards to provide
sandra's ization to to metadata and an
attempt to foster better collaboration
among the research community
and so listed here are some of the
current data elements that they've made
available and the website that you can
access to if you want to read more about
them there's also a significant
neuroscience initiative going on right
now for post-traumatic stress currently
there is a working group that is formed
from five federal US agencies that are
currently trying to develop
post-traumatic stress common data
elements and the organization that is in
charge of this is called one mind and
one mine is a nonprofit organization
that started last year and their mission
is to support research funding marketing
and awareness of mental illness and all
brain injuries they want to promote
policy improvement and increase the
research secure rate and they to do this
they want to bring you back bring
together multiple agencies to foster a
collaborative environment and as a part
of one mind they started something last
year called the Gemini program and this
is a collaboration for improving
post-traumatic stress as well as
traumatic brain injury
so to accomplish this task they're
supporting large-scale clinical data
collection programs in hopes of
developing a large information
technology structure where they can
better perform comparative comparative
research and and sharing of data among
institutions and this this these efforts
have a heavy reliance on data standards
and also of synchronizing data elements
across all agencies they use the same
terms so as a part of their knowledge
Network they're investigating
opportunities for better ways of data
curation and they're also looking to
develop common data elements for the
research community to lever knowledge of
both TBI and post-traumatic stress and
so this program is currently exploring
possibilities of storage for the data
and ontologies is one of the potential
ways of that this program might store
their data so the next project is
semantic MEDLINE and this is a project
that is currently underway at the
National Library of Medicine this is one
that I'm currently actively working on
and what semantic MEDLINE is it's an
advanced information management
application and it utilizes information
stored in documents for the explicit
explicit domain coverage and it's
provided as currently it's in prototype
version and it's accessible on the web
and I believe I give a website address
and a few slides but it's a web-based
application that displays pubmed results
in a visual manner it also provides a
summary of some of the terms that you're
searching for and these what they call
predications which is basically two
arguments linked by a relationship it's
all presented interactively you can move
this around and add and remove
different relationships in order to
focus your search so the target audience
for this is the research community and
they're essentially trying to offer an
another way to search pubmed and by
providing a visual tool to do it some of
the uses for this they promoted as a way
to do what's called literature-based
discovery which you basically look for
unknown phenomenons previously unknown
in the research literature it's it's so
support something called I guess the A
to C relationships where you look for
relationships that are not connected to
each other so essentially i guess not a
hierarchical relationships and so my
goal for this project was to expand
semantic resources expand semantic
resources covered by the umls the
unified medical language system which is
the terminology structure that the
National Library of Medicine supports
consists of about 100 different 130
different controlled vocabularies and so
in order to have a more accurate
representation of pts PTSD for the umls
what I was what I'm working on is adding
to their sim rep ontology and so similar
position is an NOP tool that extracts
these predications from PubMed and its
ability to do this crucially depends on
an accurate coverage of domain which
currently it's using the umls but PTSD
concepts are not covered very well in
u.s. and so what sim rep ontology does
first semantic MEDLINE the visual tool
it will access my ontology the sim rep
ontology and if a term is is not there
then it will access the umls so it uses
the
my definition first which is actually a
better coverage of pts and and if it's
not there only then would access umls
and so once the appropriate definition
is found it creates the predication
based upon the definition of that term
and so here what I want to give is just
kind of an example of how it goes how it
creates a predication so a common senate
you might see in literature is Sir
chillin was used in the treatment of
PTSD patients and so sim rep will
extract the arguments which are in blue
sertraline and PTSD and it also extract
the predicate which is in paint
treatment and this predicated staffs
establishes the relationship between the
two arguments in this manner circling
treats post-traumatic stress disorder
and then as a part of the umls sim rep
uses the semantic network for the
relation and the concepts come from the
met at the source and then finally each
concept within the umls has one or more
semantic types so what I'm trying to
show here in this diagram is an overview
of current coverage of PTSD in the umls
so this isn't everything obviously just
a a fractional example of it but we
define our semantic space with these
concepts and these predicates and so the
white boxes here represents concepts
along with their semantic types and the
blue boxes are the predicate and so the
semantic space is essentially a web of
connections between these these concepts
connected by relations with arrows
pointing the way that the predication is
red so for instance the bottom of PTSD
affects abuse
so kind of some of the steps that I'm
undertaking is identifying the pts the
concepts that are not in the umls and I
do this by acquiring a corpus of PubMed
citations and also from the post
traumatic stress National Center they
operate a database called pilots stands
for what is it published international
literature on traumatic stress and they
index everything on on post-traumatic
stress as well as a trauma trauma injury
anything from books to posters
literature to brochures even and I also
acquire rich citations from the dome at
domain experts that validate my findings
once I place these concepts and
relations into the ontology domain
expert tough to vet it and so then I run
it through some sim rep and then
identify what's missing some of the new
terms that are found recently where
cognitive problems were not in the umls
and then also had the add synonyms for
it such as cognitive issues or cognitive
failure i believe and also some of the
some of the semantic types have to be
changed so for instance in the umls the
term imagery is a type of mental process
but actually for posttraumatic stress
it's a type of therapy so that's just as
one of the examples of the type of
things that are making changes to and so
this is a continual iterative process
we're constantly revising the semantic
space based upon new information as it
comes available
and so what I'm showing here is just a
that I've enhanced the semantic space
essentially the the red boxes are new
relations that I've added as well as the
pink boxes are some of the new concepts
that that I've added and so what I'm
trying to show here is that these
iterations of of adding the concepts
create just creates a much more richer
understanding of the post-traumatic
stress disorder domain and so on
personal time for a live demo but again
here's the website address if you want
to play with it this is interactive
graph you can move them around what
you're kind of looking for is all these
unique clusters of new information that
you may have not have seen before these
arrows that you point on you can right
click on them and it's the these are the
relations and it will give you at the
bottom the citation where it found that
predication from so you can explore more
information and so the last project I'm
going to talk about is a project with
the VA it's called the cheer project and
Cheer stands for consortium for
healthcare informatics research and this
is a multidisciplinary group that is a
group of investigators collaborating
around the VA's from around the country
that want to use unstructured text in
the clinical narrative so currently the
VA has not been able to extract terms
describing treatments and symptoms in
their EHR and so one of the their
projects was to understand how
clinicians document clinical information
about post-traumatic stress to patients
and so they were tasked with creating a
reference tool that's capable of
classifying these concepts and so a
schema was developed from Mystic
existing pts knowledge sources and they
also did clinical interviews as well as
a literature review
news and information from expert panels
but before the information extraction
can take place several rounds of
annotating has to be done and annotating
simply just highlighting words in the
text and applying attributes and
relationships to them and so the notes
that we're currently annotating are all
notes from PTSD patients so it's all
rich and in terms that is used in that
domain and so what kind of showing here
is this a arbitrary clinical text that
we use the schema and this is an example
of an annotation tool at the bottom
right and so as we read through a
patient's note or just highlighting
important terms that we want to be able
to extract automatically
and so after after we finished with this
annotation process what the VA is hoping
to be able to do with it is to produce a
knowledge base that they're able to
perform machine learning techniques and
different natural language processing
tasks in order to start looking at the
relationships between symptoms and
treatment and another option is to
arrange the these concepts into a usable
format such as a creation of an ontology
and what does unique about this project
is typically ontologies are created from
existing literature and then domain
experts add the terms but what is unique
about this one is that all terms are
coming from clinical texts and so
they're also reviewed by the domain
experts but by all the terms coming from
clinical texts you're getting a really
rich coverage of the domain of PTSD
and so I want to talk about some of
these gaps that these researchers is
missing so you would think some 50 years
ago and we start we first started
calling this shell shock that we
wouldn't have problems with diagnosing
and and and and and thinking about
symptoms this heart this is an article
from about about three weeks ago this is
just up the road here at madigan army
medical center in Tacoma there is a
controversy about forensic side
psychiatrists are going back and
changing people's diagnosis without
discussion with the patients and so
there's a lot of controversy and that
the medical director was put on
administrative leave and it's not just
here it's all over the country and it's
not just the VA's it's in community
hospitals as well it's still obviously a
complicated disorder and whether
difficulty in this diagnosis it's it's
no wonder that are our treatments have
not been as promising is they really
should be so some of the gaps I want to
talk about is I've already been
discussing the gaps in umls coverage
both for literature and for clinical
notes so again it's the umls does not
cover these terms very well it's not
sufficient for published literature and
it's even worse for for clinical notes
so and also because of this high
screening that that we are the high
prevalence of pts that we've been
talking about there's a gap in screening
current screening tools are manual and
often considered long and time-consuming
many patients will deny symptoms because
of this the stigma and there's also a
frequent refusal of these tools because
of considered to have long long
questions and so a lot of studies site
lacked of acceptability of these manual
of screening tools there's also work
flow issues where many providers do not
have time to complete complete them in
their other seeing patients
and also an issue of non-specialists
that performed the screening non screen
non-specialists especially during a
patient's initial evaluation recurrence
of the traumatic event can have can
cause damaging and if a damaging effects
and if the specialist is not trained to
work them through their experience
symptoms can often become worsening and
there's also a need for secondary
analysis of finding symptoms in the
claret and the clinical narrative and so
kind of thinking as an upstream event
intervention there's a gap in risk
prediction and the various studies that
have looked at risk prediction and pts
has not had very good results in fact
the a big study was completed in 2009 by
the National Institute of Mental Health
and the VA and they found a lot of
potential but there's no groundbreaking
no groundbreaking findings and so it's
currently not possible to differentiate
trauma survivors who naturally recover
to people who develop long-term symptoms
a problem with the study's many of them
are performed in isolation of other
predictors and few have been able to
acquire multiple predictors to optima to
optimize it and a lot of this has to do
with not being able to get this free
text that is located in the clinical
narrative then obviously this studies
over our past decades have not found
good evidence of what works for PTSD and
what doesn't work there's no universally
accepted treatment for PTSD there's a
lot of things that work well but nothing
nothing is appears to help there's no
rule actual recovery definition of PTSD
and a large systematic review that was
undertaken by the Institute of Medicine
there working group on PTSD at the
request of the VA they are they did a
large systematic review that looked at
about 300 3000 abstract
and they found a lot of methodology
methodologic limitations and
inaccuracies they found for both for
psychotherapy and pharmacotherapy
there's not sufficient evidence
determine efficacy of treatment so their
major finding was to recommended a
full-scale research on every treatment
modality for PTSD and there's also a gap
in policy management we mentioned the
difficulty of keeping up with new
information and this includes new
guidelines that are constantly changing
dsm-5 is actually should be coming out
this summer there's a lot of a lot of
the new guidelines also often come with
like a multi a large number of different
change in criteria for diagnosing it and
so these these policy changes aren't
just for the VA again it's
community-wide so some of the ways that
are possible to address this like I said
there's opportunity to enhance umls you
know but this is through the application
development and such as I'm showing with
semantic MEDLINE and it's also a good
time to start thinking outside of Amedda
ways to develop applications to access
other information and other databases as
well and there's a lot of left work left
to do for clinical concepts obviously
there's an additional concepts such as
stressor event symptoms and functional
accepts and assessments need to be
researched and so again with screening
because of the subjective nature of
symptoms and diagnosis this is a good
opportunity to automate our screening to
overcome non-specialists that are trying
to perform the screening also this might
be more acceptable automated screenings
of patients especially overcoming
uncertainty of terms or difficulty
answering questions and for veterans
that seek outside care the V
these tools are also helpful in the
communities of with people that aren't
necessarily used to dealing with
post-traumatic stress issues
so since we are already acquiring
patient characteristics anyway in
extracting PTSD itsz concepts this the
screening kind of leads into a risk
prediction if we support these we
support these risk prediction studies
with a solid knowledge base hopefully we
can have some better results in the
benefit of being over its predicted
accurately is we were able to focus
treatment on our high-risk population
and apply interventions that are
appropriate for the specific populations
and this kind of flows into treatment an
application ontology should be able to
extract the therapy information in the
narrative task and help us with decision
tools for recommending treatment which
often is related to patients preferences
preferences and as well as the symptoms
that they're experiencing and so making
this large this data to available to
providers is an increasing challenge a
lot of new therapies are coming
available and it's hardest for these
providers to keep up with the new
information and by being so easily
absolute in a robust knowledge
representation where it can start
helping us provide more personalized
treatment to patients and as I said
about the DSM changes ontology
structures are also robust and sound to
keep up with these types of changes
there's a lot of diverse specialized
databases out there and so there's an
opportunity for applications to use a
knowledge base that that that allows
data sharing between these different
types of data databases there's also
these automation technique can help
overcome work for workforce capacity
some of the regional disparities of
having providers not really available in
rural area areas and this automation
leads to a lot of secondary uses such as
a bow surveillance and research on the
population health so what I was trying
to show here I'll probably don't have
time to go through this but I'm just
kind of trying to show a simple
inferencing problem often when we think
it's ontology is we just think of it's a
reference terminology but it actually
does much more this was just a simple
diagnosis example
this ontology is influencing
relationships about different patients
made of data that I've entered and it's
a diagnosing this patient with a chronic
PTSD and so there's other types of uses
of that ontology does there's other
other ways to arrange it there's a
rule-based there's also a
probability-based which might be more
useful for recommending treatments where
there's a lot of uncertainty of
information so these are some of the
potential research questions that are
possibly could explore what model of
knowledge representation is appropriate
to support medical software applications
is is these designed ontology ziz is
that what we need or can we get by with
static structures and just rely on
programming and machine learning and by
appropriate we also need to consider the
cost of maintaining and keeping these
ontologies updated another question as
knowledge source for applicate as a
knowledge source for applications is it
more efficient to expand Yuma's coverage
or build a knowledge base from scratch
there's been several studies that have
that have used the OMA lesson obviously
it does not cover clinical domain very
well especially with mental health but
it's several studies of had good results
as using it as a base to acquire terms
and then add to it but that's a good
question and a lot of the problems that
we've had is he's not operating in silos
because people have been developing
their own database and definitions
independently so it can we the question
is can we use common definitions that
would promote interoperability between
different research projects
never screening is there a difference
between accuracy of automated screening
or the manual screening there's a lot of
considerations about automated screening
is and how it affects workflow and
accuracy there's again these symptoms
that show up a long time after the
trauma so people aren't always
constantly looking for them so an
automated techniques might have good
results with mining data and then lastly
can we identify risk predictors for the
prediction of post-traumatic stress with
the support of a more robust knowledge
representation structure so once we
overcome the difficulty of extracting
terms it kind of starts to lead us down
of a road of developing decision support
the question to think about is can we
share information between these growing
number of databases without it where can
we implement something that will foster
better collaboration and able to
identify these risks faster risk factors
over a number of databases throughout
the community and so what I'm trying to
show here is a summary summary of some
of the objectives and capabilities of
the different projects that i will be
working on also included a application
ontology here at the end which I think
has potential to combine some of the
benefits of each of these projects
so again my focus is on knowledge
representation and building a knowledge
base that supports biomedical
applications biomedical applications and
tools in the long run these techniques
and methods of building these should be
transferable to other types of trauma
besides just combat and ultimately other
anxiety disorders as well so as in this
chart you see some of the sorts of
differences and there's also some Oprah
overlaps of things are trying to
accomplish and likely there's probably a
lot of synergies available as well and
all of these researchers need much of
the same data but they need it with
different meaning or different context
and so this makes semantics and this
domain very important but as I started
thinking about this project you know as
a lot of these standards that are
developing is coming to the mainstream
this is perfect timing for for these
organizations and researchers to start
coming together and collaborating and
agreeing on terms and defining rules of
how we're going to use this information
and I think this can ultimately lead to
greater understanding of post-traumatic
stress and so lastly along with my
knowledge management tasks that I want
to pursue in developing applications I
kind of also see this as an opportunity
to put my in fermentation skills
together and be a Bridger between each
of these research projects and bring
them together to for better
collaboration I want to thank my adviser
Joe Nash and also all of be my students
and faculty thank you to the ohsu use
ontology development group the cognitive
science branch at the National Library
of Medicine and the national library of
medicine for my training grant thank you
yes bill yeah to two related questions
one is you know have you looked at
sno-med as a source of terms and I know
that sno-med as part of the mls benefit
source and then the second question is
in terms of the sort of augmentation of
the mls met at the source that
historically the umls met at the sources
has really been a terminology of
terminologies can like a meta
terminology without its own sort of
structure and extensions but is this
some rep project which I'm only
minimally familiar with actually trying
to extend the umls met at the source or
what well I guess that's a question that
what is it actually trying to do well it
matches that one first so it's it's
trying to not really extend it but
enhance it it's a separate source of
knowledge the simmer up ontology a lot
of the so we can't really you know a lot
of the terms that they I guess at
National Library of Medicine they've
deemed strictly for pharmaceutical and
so there's certain relationships that
they that they in order to make it work
correctly for I guess the applications
that they've built they don't want them
changed so an alternative is is to
develop an external source of knowledge
so it's enhancing its not really
expanding it I guess it's how you think
about it so the again the application
that I'm using semantic MEDLINE it
accesses this this hierarchical
representation first and if it's not
there then it goes to look at you mls so
we're not changing anything in umls its
remaining the same and so your first
question Elizabeth so yes so when I talk
about you MA I'm kind of talking about
sno-med because that's the main clinical
terms that they're looking at and so a
project that i can think of for
post-traumatic stress they looked at
acquiring they a group of experts got
together and decided some main
categories of terms that they need they
came up with a list of about 153 and I
think sno-med was about 80% then they
also looked at ways that words and you
molest can be combined together and use
together and that increased it up to
about ninety percent so there's good
coverage for the basic categories but
when we start wanting to do
sophisticated things with our
applications we need something above and
beyond these general categories they
need to be a little more specialized
Erin how do you know when your ontology
is good enough in those particular
that's a great question and that's one
of the great questions of ontology is
how to evaluate it and there's no real
good answer but the the textbook answer
is never good enough it's constantly
being added to because there's
constantly new information coming and
there's a constantly new researches that
changes old ideas so the general rule is
it's vetted by experts and kind of when
they deem it good enough it's good
enough even though it never really is
yeah so my comment might be that it
while it's true that that ontology is
always continue to evolve and never seem
to be good enough in sort of a general
sense I think that there is in fact a
adequate way of evaluating ontology and
of course this is a whole area of
research but specifically from the kinds
of things that you're talking the you
know the standard procedure is to come
up with a set of competency questions
that you would use to say well does the
ontology actually function to answer
these questions and in the case of an
application does the application run and
do the kinds of things that the
competency questions suggest that it
should do and I think in developing or
extending existing ontology one or more
that's something that that's really
important to keep in mind you can't
model the world you have to model the
things that you're trying to answer
questions for yes so you can evaluate
them as use cases with application that
you're developing does your application
work correctly or not any other
questions
okay so I mean yeah I mean I agree and I
was kind of looking for something you
know more along the lines of you know
within a given application we can assess
the you know amount of you know the
coverage and accuracy of the concepts
that are relevant to that you know
application if you know what kinds of
would be look how common or what
concepts come up that can't be
incorporated or that there's some
ambiguity or confusion over and you know
and I think that's a reasonable thing to
do within a particular you know
application of an ontology in its
current state
thank you